this is jocko podcast number 341 with
carrie helton and me jocko willink good
evening kerry good evening also joining
us tonight dave burke good evening dave
good evening
to steve prizenka who showed us how to
soldier
to henry deboer who showed us how to die
to glover john's who showed us how to
lead
and to all the doughboys the ground
pounders the grunts the american
infantryman
past present
and especially future
to them
this book is dedicated
and that of course
is the opening dedication of the book of
outface by colonel david hackworth
and
i guess it's been a steady sort of just
constant in my life to be reading this
book over and over and over
again and
i was thinking about that line the other
day to glover john's who showed us how
to lead
and that's a that's a bold statement
right
for him to put in the beginning of the
book
to talk about glover john's who showed
us how to lead
and i and i started thinking about
i don't think i'd really given the
the attention that i needed to or that
i've that i've needed to to glover
john's now look we've talked glover
john's we've covered glover john's on
this podcast he wrote the book the clay
pigeons from saint lo we covered on
podcast 87
but in this book
hackworth kind of breaks down some of
the stuff that he said
some of his some of glover john's
leadership philosophy in a simple
straightforward
and powerful way that is
well worth studying definitely some
things that we can get into so yeah if
you want to go listen to podcast 87 go
back and do that
this is going to be about the leadership
principles not about the battle of saint
lo
at the the clay pigeons
so
before we get into that let me give you
the a little bit of background in case
you're just gonna jump into this podcast
about glover john's this is from about
face here's a little intro
to who glover john's is
hackworth says i was to report to eighth
division first battle group 18th
infantry
it was a nice twist of fate the unit was
a direct descendant of the us 18th which
my great great grandfather jeremiah and
his oldest son george washington
hackworth belonged to when they fought
their hackworth cousin billy
who was with the bedford's forest's
fourth tennessee cav
during the civil war
so he's this kid has a connect can you
imagine having your relative be fighting
for the union army and you're in the
same unit
legit
the 18th was military perfection men
stepped smartly across meticulously kept
grounds starched uniforms blue infantry
scarves dazzling shine brass and boots
snappy salutes and cheerful good
afternoon sirs marked my journey to the
hq where i'd sign in the spirit of this
fine unit was already infecting me
the hot stifling windless day the ragged
the ragweed pollen that blew in from the
adjacent fields covering the camp and
immediately activating my hay fever
the run-down boring camp itself none of
it mattered i was inwardly as inwardly i
was transported to an island oasis
untouched by turbulent seas
and it was all thanks to one man
the battle group commanding officer who
would forever after be my model mentor
and friend
colonel glover s johns was the finest
senior infantry commander i'd ever seen
or would ever see again
we shared a mutual abiding respect
almost from the moment we met he was my
kind of soldier and i was his he was a
warrior patton's aid before world war ii
then during the war he'd hit the beaches
of normandy as part of the 29th division
and fought from those bloody beaches
from those bloody shores all across
europe until victory was achieved
as a battalion commanding officer he'd
headed the task force that captured the
critical french town of saint lo
chronicled in his own hard-hitting book
the clay pigeons of saint lo
in korea he'd served as exo
then regimental commander in my own 40th
division his reputation there was
awesome one story that made its way
through the division was that a wild new
exo had come to the 224th gotten down on
his belly in the mud to check the unit's
machine gun fields of fire and promptly
moved two thirds of the machine gun
bunkers that had sat there for two years
i'd immediately thought of my own
fighter company
renovations and wish to hell that this
savvy character had been assigned to the
223rd
i noticed that his blue eyes sparkled
like those of a wise and truly tested
man who'd long since realized that humor
could be found in just about anything
he had seen his share of horror
his cheeks were rosy and the dueling
scar that crossed one of them in no way
detracted from his rugged yet gentle old
soldier face
the scar maybe the scar even enhanced it
i don't know but it sure gave him more
character and provided a good yarn to
boot
in any event colonel glover johns was a
49 year old stud
so there you go i think stud if you
don't know anything about hackworth stud
is the highest category of a human
that you can give
that's that's the pinnacle of
of uh
respect coming from him stud
and in fact he has studs or duds he says
that a bunch in the book there's two
kinds of people studs duds
uh
some basic info
some more info let me give you some more
info on glover johns born in 1912 in
austin texas grew up in corpus christi
texas his father went to vmi class of
1908 but got kicked out for hell raising
i mean what what does that even mean is
that in your record does it go in your
record are they like oh yeah dave burke
was kicked out of this school for
hellraising
uh so his dad gets kicked out but his
uncles he got two uncles they go to vmi
1915 and 1921.
he glover johns ends up going to
going to vmi he's a rifle pistol
marksman good at cross country
graduates with a degree in chemistry
class of 1931 goes over to germany
studies first semester he gets married
he has a son he gets divorced and he's a
civilian by the way
you know and i couldn't quite forget
he's i think he's a national guard guy
but he's working at a bunch of just
normal
normal work life
some alkali company he works at the
chamber of converse he writes for the
local newspaper
but as part of the texas national guard
he gets called to active duty in 1940
and he pretty much begs and maneuvers to
get a job going into combat which he
ends up getting and going to omaha beach
he goes on goes into omaha beach on
d-day
and d-day plus one so one day deep into
d-day he takes over the battalion
because apparently his the person that
was the battalion commander was not
getting after it
so he replaces this weak commander
and it goes right into the the hedgerow
fighting which
band of brothers you know if you know
anything about d-day that hedgerow
fighting was insane
they take
crazy casualties in his first day as
battalion commander he loses two radio
operators and three is three of his
battalion staff battalion staff
you're losing battalion staff this is
not a battalion staff that sits in the
rear when you lose two radio operators
and three of your battalion staff
constant combat um
he he's in a leadership position in the
battle of saint lo
and just to refresh your memory on that
the 29th division lost more
soldiers in the battle of saint louis
than they did on omaha beach
so
he ends up
11 months in command
he's awarded three silver stars two
bronze stars and purple heart
by the end of the war
john's unit clever john's unit had lost
2 400 men casualties
that's two and a half times bigger than
the number of people in his unit right
you know your battalion size is
what six 600 people 700 people 500
people something like that
and they had had two 2 400 casualties
he's married gets married again after
the war uh does some has another couple
sons he does peacetime tours in bulgaria
and turkey korean war kicks off he
maneuvers again to try and get to go
over there he does commands the 224th
infantry regiment the 40th infantry
division fought in the punch bowl um in
korea gets done with korea goes to army
war college goes to vmi
as the rotc leader eventually becomes
the vmi commandant
and in 1960 he becomes commander of the
first battle group 18th infantry eighth
infantry division and he goes into this
whole berlin standoff
when
when they were building the wall when
there's all these tensions and he has to
march
or
yeah pretty much marching um 1500
soldiers right into
right into berlin
right through east germany they kind of
face down the the soviet union there's a
little
there's a little anecdote in here that
there was some guard some russian guard
or some east german guard that wasn't
opening a gate when they showed up they
need to get through and he it was a
bridge or something like this
and the guy says
something you know like we're not
opening this gate
and he says well you know you have to
open this gate he's like no
he says this will start world war three
if you come here and then glover johns
pulls out his 45 and says you're gonna
be the first casualty of world war three
and that's who it opens the gate
it sounds too good to be true right it
almost does right yeah but i don't know
it man it sounds like legend yeah it
could be it could be oh by the way the
scar on his face
everyone said he got it in a duel but
actually there's a footnote about it
here uh john's received the scar in an
automobile accident in taipei he was
drunk at the time and barely missed
receiving a general court martial upon
his recovery
um
yeah
because they call it a dueling story
everyone thought so legends man legends
there's some word that can come out it's
not true i i really want to believe the
one about the first casualty of world
war ii yeah you're going to be the first
casualty yes they're private
but it was a big deal and this was a
huge event in in the early 60s that
whole standoff with the with the soviets
and after that was done
he took a job as an attache in spain
that was his last army job retired in
austin texas he was a technical advisor
on the movie patton
pretty legit
died of cancer in 1976. his ashes are
spread at vmi
so
there you go now hackworth worked for
him
and he worked for him during that march
for into berlin
and there's great account of all that
stuff and what they thought that was
going to happen i mean world war iii was
on the line this was a standoff between
two giant nuclear superpowers
and
the the word was if world war three
starts all these that entire regiment's
getting wiped out immediately because
they're just they're just no one's going
to be able to help them
there's a quote in here that's from
colonel john
um in the book about face he says i
drove hard and raised hell when i didn't
get what i wanted i made waves i bitched
about supply procedures i fought for my
men if i thought them unjustly accused
by a higher hq
i fought problems
too hard
from a love of my men as opposed to
someone else's men or my own bosses
interests because i had identified too
closely with them due to my world war ii
experiences
i think i saw too many men killed and
bled too deeply inside with the result
that i was overprotective
and hackworth goes on to say
overprotective he may well have been but
colonel johns translated his love for
his men into one thing that would save
them when he was not there
to wield the sword himself good
realistic training esprit de corps and
high morale
or unabashed cockiness some might say
within the units in his command
so
the last thing is uh
john's eventually
got orders out of the battle group in
berlin so so hackworth is there with him
in berlin and he gets orders to go do
something else and he gives a farewell
speech and during this farewell speech
according to hackworth he
john's broke down
the basic philosophy of soldiering which
he had which hack said was like being
let in on the secret ingredients of some
magical formula that's
think about that
this is hackworth saying he gets this
list of things and it's in the book and
you read it in a page you're like okay
cool
and and hack says it's like a secret
ingredient of a magical formula this is
obviously something we should be paying
attention to and this is why i kind of
got drawn back into it
so
here is leading and soldiering according
to
colonel glover johns
who taught us how to lead
the first one
is strive to do the small things well
strive to do the small things well
there's a quote how you do anything is
how you do everything this is similar
idea right because if you let the little
things go
then what happens to the big things
you guys had to be super anal in in
the fighter pilot community
yeah
there are things you got to be anal
about and i think you certainly have to
have a philosophy
of
it's the little things that will kill
you
if you don't do the little things well
it's really hard to do the big things
well
obviously there's a balance inside there
but
yes how do you so you know some people
are really detail-oriented some people
are not detail-oriented you got every
spectrum in between right yep how do you
get uh
like who's who's in charge of the
plane's maintenance your planes
maintenance so dave burke you have your
plane would you have a tail number on
your plane is that how you identify your
plane
yeah you have a number and your name on
it your names oh so so dave burke's
plane but i don't always i don't fly
that plane all the time but yes i've got
a plane okay but i gotta play like my
plane is there someone
that's in charge of that plant yes
and is he owned that plane more than you
do kind of yes
and what's his what's his job
he's a what we would call a power line
mechanic and that means the aircraft
itself he's assigned to that aircraft
and he is responsible for that aircraft
being airworthy meaning it's legit to
fly how many aircraft is he responsible
for usually one one yes
so this is your this is your guy yeah if
you're gonna have a relationship inside
the squadron and you're flying an
airplane the plane captain of that plane
you should have a good relationship so
he's called the plane captain yeah what
rank is he probably a lance corporal or
a corporal
dale he's a young kid
a huge response he's 22 years old 22
year old corporal 22 year old corporal
and he's the plane captain yes
okay so well the question i was going to
ask is and man i thought that guy was
going to be an e7
no
marine corps don't play they're like you
are responsible 100.
so
the question i was going to ask is you
got people that are
naturally very detail-oriented you got
people that aren't
do are they screening people out when
they go to a school are they going to a
school where they're like oh yeah
slipknot over here he ain't gonna be in
charge of a plane we're gonna put him in
charge of you know something else yeah i
would imagine the criteria to make sure
those people get to where they're
supposed to be and eventually be
responsible for an aircraft there's some
things along the way that they've had to
screen for but i mean this dude's only
been in the marine corps for like three
years well that's the marine corps god
um
yeah i mean even getting into aviation i
think there's probably some attributes
that they screened for initially you
know on even which basic mos or what
basic um part of the marine corps you go
to
and then inside that certainly
um even though it's i think a relatively
fast screening process the process to be
qualified to be a plane captain is no
joke
[Music]
and then how many people does he have on
his team
uh he'll probably have one or two other
guys so you know a guy who's responsible
for an aircraft he'll have probably one
other person who's in like the training
pipeline you know getting getting
certified and getting evaluated so when
i walk out to a jet and i'm gonna go man
up that jet and go fly it the plane
captain is there and he'll have somebody
with him
and he's watching observing and then
he'll be doing more and then at some
point he'll go out a couple months later
and like hey sir you know
uh you know this other marine is going
to take the lead on today's mission or
or whatever that might be and he's kind
of doing what we call a left seat right
seat or sort of a training run
so you're saying that the gun the plane
captain he's doing work or he's not
doing is he is he turning wrenches
absolutely well the other key
responsibility that the plane captain
has this is different in other services
but in the marine corps it's very
specific
the plane captain they call it power
line because you're responsible for the
line the aircraft line all the jets
you're also responsible for the power
plants so these are your engine
mechanics so in the marine corps the
engine mechanic
his other responsibility is the
nose-to-tail responsibility of that
aircraft so not only is he the guy like
literally from the nose to the tail of
that jet make sure that thing is ready
to go he's also the one that is
responsible for the engines
corporals in the marine corps
and
as you might have imagined i had a very
very good relationship with every single
plane captain of the squadron and in
fact my first real leadership job when i
first got into the marine corps
into a fighter squadron you know you
spend some time in operations you learn
how to write the schedule then they give
you a real job and my first real job was
called the power line oic so i was the
officer in charge of of the power line
division the engine mechs and the plane
captains
and
to this day probably the best job i had
and what are there 18 planes in the
squadron 12 12.
and there's one officer in charge of all
these landscapes is there a senior
enlisted yeah there's a there's a gunny
who's like the most square the most
squared away i've ever known you know
rich pilgrim if you're out there
listening he knows who he is huge huge
impact on my life
massively influential marine
and
30 plus young
marines you know they're sergeants
there's a staff sergeant but it's it's
almost all lance corporals and corporals
making it happen it's the best job ever
freaking legit
so
obviously in that scenario
doing the small things right is
mandatory
it's
i mean i remember going through the
certification process myself because i
wanted to
i wanted to know what it was like to be
certified as a plane captain so
i was young enough in my career that i
had the time to be able to do that
and
even just the questions that get asked
on these boards to certify these marines
the level of detail inside that was
indicative that
the message was they wanted the marines
to understand how important these little
little details were
because of what what was at risk if
those small details get missed
especially in
you know a really expensive really fast
machine that has this huge amount of
responsibility and says massive asset
you can't just replace
and that philosophy of the little things
will kill you
was embedded from the very very
beginning
so i read a book a long time ago it's
about desert one
and
one of the reasons that desert 1 failed
was aircraft
couldn't complete the mission and i'll
do a podcast about it at some point but
so so they wanted to get the best pilots
for desert want to go there fly into
iran and do this refueling and rescue
the hostages right
some of the pilots or at least one set
of the pilots the helicopter pilots came
from flying
air force ii what's the helicopter
what's the president's helicopter the
marine corps it's hmx-1 okay that's the
marine corps helicopters that's the
presidential helicopter so maybe it was
those guys
and those guys
they're not playing around any issue
with any that bird at all and it's not
flying yeah and so there's in the
main rotors on a helicopter there's
hydrogen
inside there's like a tube that has a
hydrogen in it and then there's a
hydrogen sensor that will tell you if
there's something wrong if there's a
crack if there's something wrong with
those blades this hydrogen sensor goes
up oh we got a problem with our blades
we need to land
and that's that's the way
that they keep those things safe because
you can have you know some kind of a
stress fracture or something in your in
your rotor blade and if that thing comes
apart you know you've got major issues
well
the the like the navy pilots
in
in the sea wolves they just flew with
the freaking hydrogen thing just they
would just like take it out they didn't
want to hear about it like they're
flying this thing the army pilots were
like that so there was a lot of pilots
that were
just saying hey dude you know like
whatever pretty much whatever hey get it
fixed later
and
but they had this
this attentiveness to details that we'll
say nope hydrogen we got a hydrogen we
got something wrong with our blade we
gotta land
and they left and all of a sudden now
they're short on aircraft it's one of
the things that led to it was we didn't
have these kind of
combat experienced pilots like if that
would have been a sea wolf pilot
bro this guy would have been like what
so just like anything else you if you go
overboard with the small things you're
gonna miss some big things including
executing a mission yeah what's cool
about understanding how important the
small things are rather than overlooking
them is that actually gives you some
insight about what you can and can't
tolerate
meaning
if i don't pay attention to any of the
little things because i'm a big picture
guy i don't care there's some little
things that are going to kill me and i
might not might not know about it
but if i'm sort of obsessive about
knowing all those things what it
actually gives me in an airplane and
really in anything
it gives me an understanding of that
that little thing that is a little thing
we're gonna ignore that and we're gonna
press or
that little thing
it's fine now but if it leads to this
and this then we got a problem that
could get worse or that little thing
will get us killed
you gotta know what those little things
are and know whether to ignore them pay
attention to them or respond to them and
those are three different kind of key
criteria but if you don't know what
those things are you can't make those
smart decisions so you got to know those
things you don't have to react to all of
them but you got to know them how long
did it take to study to get your
certification and how
like did you have to put in some work oh
yeah
i mean i did the whole thing um
that was a several month thing and i had
a blast doing it because it was a great
way to get to know my marines and what
and really for me more than anything it
was to get to know what the challenges
were and why it was a big deal for me is
we were getting ready to go in a carrier
and they called them brown shirts they
were brown jerseys on the carrier those
are your plane captains those are your
crew chiefs
and they have the most
unappreciated unforgiving job they're
the ones out there two o'clock in the
morning trying to fix an engine hanging
over the side of an aircraft carrier so
that jet is on the flight schedule the
next day
um
really underappreciated the amount of
work and how important that work was and
i wanted to understand that so i could
help advocate to get them the things i
needed to be successful and the only way
to do that is to know what they were
going through so i went through the
entire process to get certified
to learn about that
it also is a great way to get to know
the marines extremely well but being a
brown shirt being a crew chief of a
plane captain on a carrier
man those young kids are putting in just
the most ridiculous hours doing the
hardest job in the world with almost no
thanks no appreciation at all because
what they need is to get a jet to make
the flat schedule and then you know dave
burke mans up the jet and gets all the
glory because he launches off the camera
he's out for a 45 minute air conditioned
flight totally comes back lands it turns
the keys over and say here's my rental
yeah i mean that's the joker's like hey
i took the chat i come back and i go hey
this thing's busted and i give him the
keys and i leave
and obviously i didn't want to be one of
those pilots and those pilots
exist those pilots exist
yeah yeah uh
right now just so you know there are
thousands of powerline marines listen to
this conversation that are stoked that
you're talking
how many parts do you know how many
parts are in an f-18
i couldn't even guess
do
do they have to know every individual
system or do they just in the engine the
engine yes i mean we're talking every
single thing in an engine from the front
to the back now you have airframes you
have electric you have hydraulic have
other major subsystems that these plane
captains have a general understanding of
but nowhere near the detail but when it
comes to the engine
every single thing and and i'm sure it's
true for all of them but a hornet engine
is a complex piece of machinery
so from a leadership perspective
if you strive to do the small things if
you strive to do the small things well
it's going to help you you can't become
obsessed with them
we have to be careful that that becomes
that becomes ocd right you will work for
an ocd person yes i work for an ocd seal
and it was
you know you know we work through it but
it's it's it's just like any other sort
of like mental health issue where the
person just doesn't understand that
they've got it you know and you're like
sir i do you really want yeah yeah we we
i can't we we you know whatever whatever
the case may be whether it's all the
fonts need to you get those fonts
straightened out or you know the drawing
cage needs to look like it's just
whatever the thing is
then they're losing their minds about it
and it's not healthy and you can't
convince them of otherwise
it's hard to even address it with them
because they just look at you like
you're crazy
so
don't be that person yes do the small
things well yes pay attention but don't
get obsessed with them because then you
won't be paying attention to the things
that you need to pay attention to
so that's number one
all right next one
colonel glover jones to be a doer and a
self-starter actually let me rephrase
that he actually says be a doer and a
self-starter aggressiveness and
initiatives and initiative are two most
admired qualities and a leader
but
he throws the dichotomy in there but you
must also put your feet up and think
this is interesting on 97 different
levels all right so
we're talking about being default
aggressive and this is
something that clearly he's talking
about it as well and clearly as a human
you gotta make things happen
and talking and planning and dreaming
and all that stuff doesn't matter it
actually doesn't matter what matters is
taking action
making things happen
that's what's gonna be good and
the marine corps has an awesome
mentality
and they want their leaders to have a
bias for action which is this which is
exactly what is being said here
being a doer and being a self-starter
that means
having a bias for action your your your
general move is i'm going to take action
that's what the marine corps wants their
marines to have is a bias fraction
now when i was teaching young seals
i told them they needed to be default
aggressive which is a little stronger
it's actually probably quite a bit
stronger than a bias fraction right bias
fraction is like okay yep i'm gonna yep
i'm if i'm gonna make a decision i'm
gonna take action okay cool
i needed guys to be
aggressive
things happen
and the reason is because the situations
i was putting these young seals in was
it needed more than just a bias for
action to get them going in the right
direction they needed to actually be
like oh i'm not doing anything bad
things are happening i need to get
aggressive right now
so that's where that comes from
and
and like i said if you're a person in
life
and you find yourself hesitating you
might need to program yourself to have a
default aggressive attitude not just a
bias for action and not just well i'm
gonna be a doer even be a doer is pretty
soft that's not gonna push you
through some mayhem
where things are blowing up and you're
like i'm not sure what i should do i'm
just going to sit here and wait to see
what happens no
need to go
now he says this but you also must
put your feet up and think this is the
most interest or i guess one of the most
interesting
uh descriptions of detachment
that i've heard and what a good one
let's face it there's no possible way
you can literally put your feet up and
think unless you do unless you detach
so he's saying
you got to do more than just you know
think you got to put your feet up and
think and he's saying that for a reason
he's saying that because well i guess
i'm assuming he's saying that because
he's told plenty guys hey you need to
think about what's happening and they're
like
and they still make a bad decision
you know they're just like in brain
imploding
he's saying hey take a step back look
sit down there's all this chaos going on
cool put your feet up and think
that's what i need you to do
i'm thinking of the literal sense of
that too and you you once described
talking about the idea of detachment of
when you said you're writing when you
write things down
it's a good one you were it's a literal
form of detachment
and i'm thinking of
especially like if you're a soldier it's
really hard to do anything when your
feet are up literally like and have this
picture of this person who's at a desk
feeder up on the desk
and you actually can't do or go or move
anywhere when your feet are up and even
just to start contrasting in your mind
of what he means by that which isn't
just a stop and think it's actually
put yourself in a position where you're
not doing anything while you're thinking
and then of course the dichotomy inside
there and i just can't help but imagine
the idea that
he understands that
and i think you did too in task unit
bruiser is when you start correlating a
little bit of risk of not doing
something it's not like hey we get a
little behind on the project or no we
get a we'll finish it monday instead of
friday or we get a little over budget if
you don't get this thing done in combat
the risk of that is
astonishing
and when you understand
the natural human biases not to do those
things
sometimes
pushing to the default aggressive is
actually where you have to go to get
them to get away from that natural state
which is to do nothing
yeah i think i've got this somewhere
else in this in the in my notes here but
the power curve
which is a real thing in life i know
it's a real thing in the air but we used
to use that term
that oh you you don't get behind the
power curve that means
all the stuff that you have to get done
you get behind the power curve and
you're done you can't catch up again
that's right so that's what happens in
an aircraft right
how does it work so
yeah the power curve in an aircraft is a
place literally it's a curve that they
draw and it's based on like factors like
thrust and lift is if you get behind the
power curve it requires more power than
you have than you have
which in again in that literal sense and
the curve is like once you get past that
curve
you know i think this thing is like more
power to go slower like you don't have
the power or the thrust to keep the
aircraft doing what it's doing and if
you get behind the power curve
you it is an unrecoverable thing unless
you do some other things and give up
some other things which you don't want
to do well if you're at altitude you can
put nose down you can regain your speed
yes that's what i would usually do yes
that's what you're doing
but to your point like
there's you can if you do these other
things you don't have to get there
yeah there was a
stoner was getting in he's talking to
some like command historian or something
like this
and
he he told this command historian and
the command historian showed it to me he
was he said something along the lines of
yeah well in ramadi
jaco had to beat his head against the
wall to get a mission done it was like
every every mission to make a mission
happen there was like so much stuff that
you had to do to get it to go
and
that's what it feels like when you talk
about oh
these little things like this little
document that you gotta get put out this
you gotta go run to this brief you gotta
go talk to this person there's all these
things that have to take place
and not to mention
the weapons have to be prepped the
vehicles need to be ready the plan has
to look all those things are going on
and and and if you fall back behind that
power curve you're just not going to do
it you're not going to get not going to
happen you have to be just
just full thrust you have to just keep
it there and sure after the op you can
be like okay i'm gonna back off a little
bit and and
save a little bit of gas right now but
it's not gonna take more than a couple
hours before you better put that you
better put that throttle fully down
again you better start making things
happen because they're not going to
happen on their own
um so that's good
be a doer be a self-starter be
aggressive take initiative but
just straight up
put your feet up and think about what
you're doing
so there you go that's number two number
three
strive for self-improvement through
constant self-evaluation
this is a good rule for leadership and
life
and
it's it's weird to think that number one
if you're not humble you're not doing
this right if you're not if you think
you're doing everything right you're not
doing this this just isn't happening you
have to be looking you have to be humble
enough to say what what can i do better
and you have to start off by knowing
where you are
and then and then trying to assess
what you can get what you can get better
at
and
this is a difficult thing to do you know
this is this is
you know to me this is the eminently
qualified human
you know the the the actual evaluation
of yourself which you and i wrote that
book the the code the evaluation the
protocol
and then made the the app there's an app
for it but that's the kind of thing
where you go okay i know where i'm at
right now i know what i need to do today
i know where i slacked off a little bit
i know where i can improve tomorrow and
if you're not doing that
that's why that's how rome fell apart
right rome wasn't built in the day and
it didn't fall apart in a day either
fell apart a little bit at a time just a
little bit at a time
that's what happens
that self the self-evaluation comment
and obviously immediately tether that to
the idea of humility is such an
important piece of that because and i
would see this all the time is
i would work with guys that were good at
certain things and not good at other
things and where they would spend their
focus would be
doing the things that they did well
which is important and this is not to
say that if you don't have a particular
strength that you shouldn't focus on
that strength
but because they were comfortable doing
the things they were good at they spent
all their time doing the things they
were good at and you got more experience
and more senior
the more those other gaps
became a big hindrance because you have
to be good at a lot of things especially
in a leadership role especially if you
plan on elevating in that leadership
role the awareness of hey if i'm not
good at this i have to spend time doing
the things and getting better things i'm
not as good at as i should be and how
easy it is to go well i'm pretty good at
this i'm just going to stay over here
because this is so much easier for me
and not being willing to acknowledge
what you're not good at and actually
spend some time working on that and how
easy does a phone in the trap of well
i'm good at this i suck at this which
one should i be working on today i'll
just keep doing this thing over here
and that self the self evaluation of
what do i know i'm not good at and how
easily we can just ignore what we know
we need to be working on i used to hate
being on the bottom in jiu jitsu like
someone on top they would just like
smash and i would hate the feeling right
and so for months the only place i
started was with people across the side
or mounted on me just like go ahead take
it and then just
got over it
got over it completely where it
literally didn't matter anymore
if you don't have that approach you're
gonna have problems man i'm gonna have
problems watch out for that
um and this this is tied into the next
one number four which is never be
satisfied ask of any project how can it
be done better now listen
you know you could
just if just to throw like a different
perspective on this or a different angle
the never be satisfied thing where all
of a sudden
you know i'm never satisfied and i'm you
know freaking out about and constantly
there's people that that run into issues
with that where they can't
like chill out and back off and detach
and look around and see what's happening
so never is kind of a strong word
but at the same time this is completely
tied to humility because
if you are satisfied
that's an indicator that maybe you think
you're there and you're not
you're not
this implies that the debrief to me you
know it's like
not not being satisfied with it by
looking back at it and saying hey how
could we do this better
did we miss anything or is there
something we should add to this and then
debriefing it
and then trying to you know trying it
again the next evolution yeah 100 if
you're not debriefing what you're doing
and and look if you want to take that to
a really good
personal level
if you look at your day that's what's
nice about the the eqh app it's like if
you look at your day and you're like oh
i could have done this better i just at
the end of the day going hmm
did i really i didn't really do that
i i got in on that donut or whatever
tapped in my my daughters right now they
say tapped into like if they're talking
about food they're like oh can i tap
into that so you might have accidentally
tapped into a donut or whatever right
you're gonna watch out
so
which by the way i don't think i can
ever eat a donut again because i've
talked so much smack about donuts and i
think there's someone with like a 600
millimeter lens just stalking me waiting
to see that donut
go down that hat ain't happening
but
doing a debrief with yourself at the end
of the day what did i and then and then
also creating what you're gonna do
tomorrow to focus on the weaknesses a
little bit and again like you said dave
dave wasn't like hey you know i'm gonna
focus on my piano skills because he's
not that great at piano when he's
supposed to be a jet fighter pilot right
right i get it
but
doesn't mean you shouldn't understand
music or something
you know what i'm saying doesn't mean
you shouldn't go out and get that gift
box
[Laughter]
all right
number five
don't over inspect or over supervise
allow your leaders to make mistakes and
training so they can profit from their
errors and not make them in combat
so decentralized command clearly is what
we're talking about here
and
it's it's incredible how annoying over
inspection and over supervision is to
humans
that's psychological reactants right
it's like a psychological reactance
which means we don't want to be told
what to do because we're human beings we
have a psychological rejection of people
that are trying to control us that's
normal that's common but over inspection
and over supervision just triggers the
psychological reactants all day long all
day long don't let it happen don't be
that
leader because that's not going to work
out good for you it's not your team's
not going to like it no one's going to
like it now here's where people get a
little bit
wary about this because they think
well you know i'm in the business world
and so i don't have the luxury of being
able to train someone to in in a
training situation no they gotta go in
front of a client i can't just let them
fail in training because
there's no such thing we don't do that
we don't have time i don't have six
months getting ready to go on deployment
and work with a client no i work on the
client today
so there are multiple ways of doing this
right if dave has got a dave's not
experienced in a certain type of project
and i go okay dave
you're gonna take lead on this project
why don't you come up with you know your
initial
your initial brief on the timeline you
want to use
and he puts together the timeline i
don't send him to the client with it i
say okay now brief me on it and he's
like i got 38 days to talk about cover
and move and i go no that doesn't make
sense so so you can you can actually
train and educate someone
just by putting in a little probably 20
extra effort and if you think about it
it's actually probably a break even
because i didn't have to do the bulk of
the work myself i just said hey dave
came up come up with a timeline for this
training schedule for this client and he
goes oh cool
and he goes and does it now if i would
have had to do it i would have made
couple phone calls and i would have to
do the pull out the word processor and i
would have to sit down and do it and it
would have been pain and plus i would
have been in the weeds on it so i don't
really see as much i'm not detached from
it instead i go hey dave come over the
timeline for this client what you want
to do for a basic schedule and he goes
cool got it he does it he's never done
it before or maybe he just i go here's
an old client similar client you can use
this as a as a guide cool
he does it it's pretty close right it
doesn't i'm not wasting a bunch of time
and if he was a total idiot and you
produce something that sucked i'd be
like okay cool this is this is horrible
this is why didn't cost us anything
didn't put any risk didn't show the
client some bad take on us no it's all
good so just because we use the just
because
the term
is used here make mistakes in training
don't consider training to be this
official thing where you've been pulled
away and you don't have any interaction
in the real world no training can happen
every single day with everything that
you do
and that's what you should do and you
should let people brush up against the
guardrails of failure you should let
people do that and then when they do you
don't jump down their throat and now you
don't become a micromanager you let you
make adjustments and you
set another thing for them say all right
here's hey dave this doesn't make any
sense adjust this this will never take
this much time go make some adjustments
bring it back to me dave does it hey
cool yup good to go
my net investment of time is probably
the same if not i'm probably saving time
and my product my end product is
actually better because i'm detached and
i wasn't in the weeds
on the initial assignment
so
don't over inspect don't over supervise
hard to do that your ego wants you to
over supervise by the way
your ego wants to over inspect your ego
actually wants to find problems you ever
had those bosses like you can't get
through
like in the seal teams you give a brief
there's no way you're getting through
the brief without getting dinged on
seven different things
i'd like some of the guys i used to
critique their briefs on come and talk
to me because i was freaking harsh on
those briefs but here's the thing man
i'll have to review some of my notes
cause i would be harsh because they
would do dumb [__]
and i'd be like bro what are you doing
over here what does this mean i can't
even understand look at your pictures
here like this doesn't make any sense
what is this timeline how do you think
you're gonna patrol from here to here in
that amount of time
they were just legitimate things
because i actually didn't care
i actually didn't care what the font was
i didn't care about any of that i cared
about and actually i did here's a good
case in point i had a guy good dude
tore his brief up
and you know he gets done
they do another brief next day next stop
tore it up terrible
and he's like
after the first day he added even more
like trying to satisfy me
and he says dude what this is like a
moving target what is that you actually
want from these briefs and i said well
it's not a moving target i said
to me
a good brief
is when you give a brief
your men understand
the mission and the execution
and he was like
okay fair enough and then he took that
to heart
of okay
my audience is not jocko my audience is
not the commanding officer my audience
is my machine gunner my audience is my
point man my audience is my breacher
that's my audience that's who needs to
understand this thing and that's the way
it's supposed to be and that's the same
same thing leif and i wrote about this
happened with life and seth life and
stuff were doing the the freaking most
insane 150 slide powerpoint briefs
for reconnaissance missions in training
and they were so bad and i was like hey
guys
no one knows what the hell you guys are
talking about i said let's let's do this
i said i just want you to brief to the
lowest common denominator in your
platoon just do that pull out a map
don't need to put a bunch of slides they
don't need to have animation in the
slides you know much time it takes to do
animation in the slide
i mean it's a total waste of time it's a
total waste of time you should pull up
the map and be like hey we're going to
move from here to here that's the way
it's going to work follow my finger
follow my pointer on this map so you all
know what's up instead we spend an extra
hour and 22 minutes making humvees drive
down a route in an animated way it's
it's a disaster man and the cool thing
was and props to my commanding officer
those guys
and and you guys have heard the story
like seth was like we're gonna get fired
and i said hey
there you will not get fired if anyone
gets fired i will say this was 100 on me
i told him to brief this way don't worry
about it brief to your lowest common
denominator brief to your machine
gunners and they're like okay and sure
enough the commanding officer came up he
sat through the brief and to his credit
he was like that was the those are the
best briefs we've had
i actually understand what's happening
i'm like that's the goal
so
that's what we need to do
don't over supervise don't over inspect
and and when people make mistakes just
make some little adjustments tell them
what the goal is and we're going to be
all right
yeah
i'm just cracking up listening you tell
these stories and just kind of putting
my version of that in my experience but
i think also in a leadership role it
doesn't matter for the military doesn't
matter if you're in the private sector
and whether you're training a real world
you also have to know what matters
you got to know what really matters and
what really doesn't and something we saw
in the military that i know transfers
over would drive people nuts is
if you're in a key leadership role and
you're getting this brief and you make a
comment about the font
guess what
those people all downstream you they're
going to obsess over the font
so if it really doesn't matter don't say
anything about it because what your
people are really trying to do is make
you happy they're trying to give you
what they think you want and if you're
the guy that wants to think out loud go
boy
you know
courier is way better than times isn't
it
every single slide is now going to get
reviewed three layers downstream
of someone trying to make sure oh uh
dave's real obsessive about the font
even if you're not but if you if you
want to make a point of that if you
decide to bring that up your people are
going to try to satisfy you that you're
going to try to do so be real careful
about what matters and don't talk about
the things that don't matter because
they're going to hear you and they're
going to want to fix that when in your
mind
it isn't even an important thing but
when you once you say it it's out there
that's what people we saw in the
military all the times oh this we're
briefing this general he's real big on
on on spacing
and i bet you if you grab that general
go hey general um we have to spend three
hours fixing this spacing on this brief
do you want us to do that he would say
no where did you even get that yeah but
it he made a comment or it came out and
yeah and the worst thing is you've got
people that are focused on that instead
of focusing on the content of a mission
totally and a good plan and contingency
plans so all the time
so be careful that
number six
keep the troops informed
telling them what how and why builds
their confidence this was an interesting
an interesting little twist on that
right builds their confidence
first of all lets us know the importance
of people being confident being
confident in the plan and and look when
you when you know what you're doing
but you don't know why that's a problem
for your confidence you don't even know
why you're doing it so you're just
if you know why you're doing something
but you don't know what you're doing it
for that's the same thing
so
keeping people informed
a lack of info and this was
this was one of the reasons why i was
very happy
look and i was very lucky in my career i
was very lucky in my career that i did
my career the way i did and i'm not
saying that there's a bunch of better
ways to do it because there certainly
are but for me
what what was very nice for me one of
the huge lessons that i
learned was how horrible it feels not to
know what's happening
and
the team normally doesn't know what you
think they know
they don't
you think they know stuff they don't
know it you think that they understand
things they don't it's not because
they're not stupid because they don't
have the visibility on the things that
you have the visibility on
so
it's it's very important to tell people
what's going on and by the way
and this is
it's so crystal clear in the seal teams
but it's crystal clear anywhere else but
the seal teams was just
so
so epic at doing this anything that the
troops didn't know they were gonna make
up their own freaking rumor and it was
gonna be like the worst possible case
scenario every single time
uh you know oh the we're heading back
early oh we're heading back from this
trip early you know you're probably
going because the aircraft got
rescheduled and so you're gonna head
back early people are like oh no
see our platoon's getting disbanded you
know we whatever they just go wild
so when you don't tell people what's
going on they're gonna make it up and
that's gonna be bad
and it and one of the worst feelings in
the world is to not know what's
happening in as part of a team and it
look this doesn't mean you have to
submit a 19-page powerpoint brief
especially if you can get people
the context and the context
you know if every day or every couple
days you're giving the context of or
people have the context now my brief
doesn't have to be that long it's like
hey carrie we're actually going to move
to this position you're like okay cool
because i know that here's where we were
here's where we're going if i just you
don't know have any contacts and i tell
you we're moving here
i have to actually take now 20 minutes
to explain how we got to the point where
we're gonna go there
so keep that in mind
number seven
the harder the training the more the
troops will brag
clearly this is seen in the military
and
[Music]
almost to a detriment of course because
people you can put people through so
much training and they can start to brag
so much they start to believe it
uh leif always talks about the fact
when we started tasking a bruiser and
we're working together and we were going
doing extra we were coming in early in
the morning we were staying later at
night we were doing extra iterations of
the training that we were being told to
do the training cadre would leave and
we'd stay there and do more and the
initial take was like
extra work that was the kind of initial
take
and sure enough
as we got better as we got more squared
away as we started getting
you know huge
compliments from the training cadre all
of a sudden that that
bitching turned to bragging which was
pretty which was pretty cool
and
it's the thing is though there's a speed
bump that you have to get over right
there's a speed bump there's a there's a
point in time there's an intersection of
time where you're working harder but
you're not seeing any benefits from it
you're working harder but no one really
else can see it you're working hard
you're doing extra but there's no real
benefit
and you got to that's a speed bump and
so you're going to get people being
negative this is going to work extra
we're going to do could become an early
we're legacy
thing that you're gonna have to overcome
and get to the point where all of a
sudden oh
we just crushed this block of training
we just got huge you know compliments to
our commanding officer about our
performance in land warfare or whatever
and so you got to get over that speed
bump
so that
the bragging can start and the pride can
start and then what you got to be
careful of is you got to be careful that
that pride doesn't get so big that
people think you know we don't need to
do any more we don't need to do this
anymore so
keep that in mind
and keep yourselves in check you know we
luckily we had friends in other task
units
because
it got it got pretty the bride the the
kind of the the the chest sticking out
and tasking the bruiser got a little bit
much
and
you know we'd get like some of our
friends and other task units would be
like
you know oh btf you know we're like okay
we need to back off a little i hate to
chill out everybody you know so just
just just
keep it in check a little bit um but
there's a speed bump you got to get over
that's a real thing
yeah i think there's a connection too to
the previous comment you made about the
why is it
that hard training especially when they
start to make the connection why hard
training is important
if they know why they're doing it
their your people will have so much more
resilience and be able to tolerate so
much more hard training and if you're
just out there just training hard
because that's how you are
and they can't make any connection to
all this extra time all this extra work
that it doesn't lead to something you
will run into a problem but if you can
connect that why and then go oh
this real world thing was so much easier
now the willingness to work hard and
track just to work hard in training or
put in an extra time because they know
why they're doing it makes it so much
easier down the road yeah
no doubt like you said going with the
the previous point keep the troops
informed
if you're not informing the troops and
you're just
kicking the crap out on a normal basis
it's not there's not gonna be any pride
there's just gonna be negativity so
be careful that um number eight
enthusiasm
fairness and moral and physical courage
four of the most important aspects of
leadership
in an interesting enthusiasm
out of the gate enthusiasm man
what you know why that is i in my
opinion because that is so
infectious to everybody else and when
you're enthusiastic about something
when someone on the team is enthusiastic
that can just
that can change the the attitude of
everyone on the team if you as the
leader enthusiastic it's definitely
going to help if you as the leader are
not enthusiastic about something it's a
disaster and everyone's going to be
bummed out to be doing whatever
having a good time with stuff and being
enthusiastic
that's something and you know what's
cool you can fake that
you could fake that all day long i did
i'd be like this is some dumb [__] hey
let's rock and roll like you know what i
mean
you gotta just sometimes call it man i'm
gonna be i'm gonna be fired up for this
i'm gonna take it to the next level
watch let's go and then you're just
having fun and pretty much you you fool
everyone else then you fool yourself and
you're having a good time let's do it
let's rock and roll
fairness
clearly
clearly got to be fair about what you're
doing and then moral and physical
courage
you know what's what's interesting on
these two i was thinking about it
you would think
that moral courage would be the easier
thing to have
because you're not under the threat of
physical harm right because normally i
think physical courage i think you're
risking some sort of physical
injury
so what but but i think most of the time
we we see i think we more often see a
failure of moral moral courage than
physical courage
why is that and i think it basically
boils down to most of the time with
moral courage
you have time to think about it and
physical encourage you like oh there's
something going on i need to get in
there i'm gonna go do this right now and
and even talking to guys that have done
like incredibly courageous thing i
remember mike thornton was on the
podcast medal of honor recipient vietnam
seal
and i said well you know were you scared
when you're getting ready to i forget
what it was when you were getting ready
to run across this
beach that's being
you know
just darted with machine gun fire and
grab your buddy that you thought was
dead were you would we were you scared
did you hesitate he's like no i didn't
think about it all i just had to go
so he didn't have time to think about
you know it's just like wow that's what
this is what i'm doing i'm doing it now
and there's no time to think about it
moral courage is like you have time to
weigh out what's gonna happen and what
the consequences are gonna be and what
are people gonna think and what are you
gonna think and how is it gonna feel
and i think that's why
oftentimes the moral courage can be
harder to muster up because you have
time to think about it which is
generally not fun
in the team dynamic you know moral
courage in a in a team
especially if there's like social proof
against you right the rest of the team
thinks one thing and
you think you know you're being morally
courageous and that's not what the team
thinks and that can put some some
pressure on you as a individual now
against the team and and your views
versus theirs that's a little different
dynamic as opposed to moral courage as
an individual i'm gonna do the right
thing because that's the right thing to
do
but you throw that in the team dynamic
it gets a little a little more difficult
yeah well you better have and build
really good relationships with people
that way you don't get yourself into a
predicament right
the predicament that you get yourself
into is you know dave does something
that's a little bit wrong but i don't
really know him that well and i'm like
well you know i don't really want to say
anything and then
i basically now have said hey you're
cool that what you did is cool and now
he does something a little bit further
outside the box of what he should be
doing and now i'm like wait a second now
this is this is going outside the box
but i still don't can't say anything to
dave about i haven't preempted anything
and now dave goes further outside the
box so by the time i'm like
gonna say something well now i've known
about the four things that he did that
were outside the box
i'm culpable as well now so now all of a
sudden i got it it's going to be
i
totally screwed myself
whereas if i see dave leaning outside
the box and go hey damn
hey bro what are you doing what are you
doing with this he's like well you know
something we can get away with and i go
ah
man would you really like that to be on
the cover of you know the newspaper
he's like well
yeah maybe not i mean and look i trust
you and you trust me but what about this
guy over here and that guy over there
and they're all gonna know what's
happening this doesn't seem like a smart
move man so just having a it just like
just like i always say about hard
conversations the earlier you have that
conversation the easier it's gonna be
you know i
that's something that that uh leif talks
about you know i said there's no
cover-ups into asking a bruiser there's
no cover-up so we're not covering
anything up if something happens we're
gonna tell everyone what happened if you
know if somebody gets shot something
something goes down there's no cover-ups
this is what we're doing
and right there everyone kind of goes
okay like i guess that's the way it's
going to be
and there's no
there's no you start stepping outside
the box and it's like wait a second i
already told you this
so it makes the easy it makes the hard
conversation easier out of the gate
because everybody kind of knows oh
jaclyn said there's no cover-ups
okay well we know where he stands got it
and we won't try and you know push the
envelope and when we do push the
envelope a little bit we're getting
we're getting pushed back in there real
quick
so
i think that will help you with your
moral courage number one having
relationships with people number two
have the hard conversations earlier
because that way you don't put yourself
in that freaking terrible predicament
we're like uh
dave's embezzled freaking 380 000 from
whatever you know you're like bro what
are you doing
and it's too late because i knew about
it but now i'm culpable
so let's not get there moral courage is
easier earlier
let people know where you stand
number nine
showmanship a vital technique of
leadership
one of the things that uh isn't isn't
about face
i guess colonel
glover john's was like a crack
shot
super
accurate shot and he would walk down the
range and like let me see your rifle son
and he'd say you got a quarter on you
and he'd have him throw a quarter up in
the air and he'd shoot the quarter and
these were like prized possessions to
have a quarter that was shot by gov
glover john's these the kind of things
that he did
um
so that's
something that you know
something that is good to be able to to
show people that you got something i
mean the seal team's being able to shoot
move and communicate
is a good thing you know
you got to be a good shot you don't want
to be a loser shot
you know i was definitely never the best
shot i was usually fast i was pretty
fast out of the holster
so i could do well in a speed shooting
but then you know you get out some uh
the my accuracy wouldn't be as good as
like our really good shooters the guys
were freaking really good but shoot move
and communicate you know are you in good
shape can you
hey if you're lagging if you're in a
leadership position you're lagging on a
patrol like you need your weight you
can't carry your weight that's a problem
right that's a problem if you don't know
how to work your radio that's a problem
these are just like little things
right
and honestly jiu jitsu is pretty good
little showmanship thing
you know
you want to roll
hey it's kind of a kind of an issue to
work with you know um
and i've tried man when i talk about i
was on i was on the academy the other
day and i brought this up i brought this
up this idea of showmanship and
when
to actually say
let me show my boss how good my team is
like sometimes you got to do things like
that and it very counter to what i say
99 of the time which is hey you work
hard
don't worry about the res don't worry
about who sees it but sometimes all of a
sudden you're thinking well if we don't
if the boss can't see what we're doing
we're not going to get these extra funds
we're not getting this extra personnel
how do i set this up so my boss can
actually see so i can take care of the
team better
so there are times when showmanship is
going to play a role in you being able
to take care of your team better that
happens
how much of how much showmanship did you
do flying an f-18 at the top gun school
dang
yeah i mean i i think i think that
ability
to be a little bit of a showman is a is
i mean it's important a bunch of ways
even you were just talking a minute ago
you're talking about enthusiasm and
you're like hey what's cool about that
is you can fake it
and that even there's a little bit of
showmanship of
you were gonna present yourself as if
the situation that we're in no matter
what it is it's totally awesome this is
gonna be a blast we're gonna we're gonna
whatever
and
it's really not that hard to even
pretend to be injured in some interested
in something as opposed to walking in
like
okay
here we go and how instantaneously you
can set the tone and if you in the back
your mind recognize that part of being a
showman is that people are going to
follow they're going to
they're going to reflect that back to
you they're going to guide off your
behavior and whatever you you show them
they're going to show them back that
showmanship of how your attitude is
going to be towards anything and how
quickly you can come into your half your
team's attitude just by showing that
this is going to be fun or a good time
and even if they know you're faking it
they get on board um
the idea that you have to kind of play
the game a little bit and sort of act a
little bit as in in in a leadership role
and how easy it is to do that
uh is such an overlooked thing yeah and
i as you were saying that i broke
something down and i realized something
about myself that is
a tactic technique and procedure that's
probably very important and it's
something that i've probably done my
whole career
i'm not going to rely on being a good
actor
i'm not going to be even rely on faking
it what i'm going to do is i'm going to
figure out in my own head how this makes
sense how
how this makes sense for me to be able
to do what i'm going to do to the nth
degree
like i can tell you here's one when i
was going to college
i didn't want to work i didn't want to
do these read this book and write this
paper do this all the stupid stuff i
turned it into a competition in my head
against the teacher
i was fighting against the teacher i
wanted to know more of the teachers i
made that in my head where i was like oh
i'm going to crush this teacher they're
not they're not going to ask me one
question that i don't know the answer to
that's not happening and so i turned in
a competition in my head that was fun
but i do the same thing like
if my platoon got tasked with doing
something stupid i'd be like oh guess
what i'd turn it into a game my head
that i really did want to win and i
really wanted a platoon to win so i'd be
like oh guess what we got tasked with
doing this stupid hydrographic
reconnaissance we're going to take it so
seriously that that the command is going
to be like oh my god we're going to
leave an impression on them from doing a
hydrographic reconnaissance that they're
going to think we're the most squared
away guys ever watch this and all of a
sudden instead of i would truly believe
that i would tr i'd be like hell yeah
so i i think that was my tactic
and my technique was to truly find what
was good about some situation and
completely focus on that 100
because then then i'm not trying to
because you know i always say you can
smell you can smell
uh
intent has a smell right so if i'm like
well this is a stupid hydrographic
reconnaissance but i'm gonna pretend
like it's good
guys are gonna smell that but if i go
hey they're making us do a hydro we're
going to we're going to blow their minds
when they get this chart that we give
them and we're going to give it to them
all of a sudden i was like hey yeah yeah
like they're going to want to test
everyone else they're going to give all
the other hydros to the other platoons
because they're going to know we know
what's up where our goal is to make us
never get tasked with the hydrogen
because they see that we know how to do
it so well boom and all of a sudden
everyone's amped up
and that's what i did probably more than
anything else
i remember i did that at an officer
candidate school at officer candidate
school
you have to follow all these rules and
one of them is speaking in a ballistic
tone which means you have to yell
everything and i would just i told my
whole class i'm like when you because
you had to do it to the senior the
classes above you the senior classes
you had to you were supposed to talk in
a ballistic tone to them and i said
and it was kind of annoying and i said
you should be so loud we're gonna be so
loud that it's gonna annoy them so that
was it also just like you could see
carrie smile and you're smiling like
that all of a sudden became fun we were
trying to be so loud when we were
talking to the senior classman that it
was annoying it wasn't annoying to us it
was annoying to them
and that's exactly what we did as a
matter of fact one time we were all
lined up to buy they would sell us candy
bars right and so my classes lined up
with the senior classes selling us cokes
and candy bars to make money so they can
make a t-shirt or something like this
and you and they're selling from this
little closet thing
and i had i said hey when you guys go in
there you go ballistic
and so sure enough there's
50 or 60 people in my class by the 25th
person the
upperclassman like steps out in the
hallway
attention candidates when you get in
this office you are not to sound off in
a ballistic tone and what did i do
i stepped out i was like you know uh
officer candidate willing request
permission to speak like what i'm like
you know uh according to the freaking
rulebook 7-9
we are supposed to maintain ballistic
tone at all times
and they they cowered to it they were
like
fine and so we just went in there and
screamed our head off came all headaches
so i'm gonna take something like that
i'm gonna find a way to make this fun
and good
and i think that might be a more
reliable tool
than
my acting ability which i can't really
count on
yeah and it's not even that hard you
even said it inside there you're like
watch this that's showman show he's like
hey you want to give me that thing
watch this
and yeah i think you know obviously the
semantics of the word you want to be
careful with that you you don't want to
fake anything in terms of
hey i don't really believe this but i'm
going to do it you got to find the truth
that's inside there but if there's
something just like hey we got to do
this thing
watch this yeah and how quickly people
rally around then and get on board and
it gets done it's good to go and you
move on yeah and it's not that big of a
deal hell when i was going through buds
in third phase we
i would
me and my swim buddy would voluntarily
get wet and sandy
and eventually they'd you know the
instructions like why are you getting
wet and sandy we'd be like to get harder
to be harder and they didn't want us to
get wet and sandy on like the
electric blasting range so you're doing
demolition on a range and and they want
you to be dry and stuff and we they
ended up securing our class saying you
guys are not allowed to get wet and
sandy and then we got wet and sandy and
slept outside and they were like what
are you doing
and like just trying to get harder
so a little psychological game we're
gonna have fun with this that's what
we're doing rock and roll uh showmanship
keep it in mind
number 10
the ability to speak and write well two
essential tools of leadership
here's the thing that i think people
underestimate you can get better at both
these things
and as a matter of fact you can get
insanely better at both these things
writing for sure
uh a one tip out of the gate if you're
not much of a writer right now write and
then read what you wrote aloud and see
what it sounds like and you're gonna see
that you suck
you suck at writing
when you write something and you read it
a lot new this sounds awful yep that's a
great first indicator
and the more you practice and then find
somebody to read it for you and critique
it and you will get better at writing
you will become more clear you'll become
more concise you'll become a better
writer over time and that will
that will reflect in the way that you
speak as well
and also the more you speak to groups
the more you speak aloud that's one of
the reasons why they had you do that ocs
that's why you had to yell everything
because they wanted you to get confident
in your voice and get confident in
thinking and speaking
quickly
and the way the drill instructor told us
he said
you know you young officers are going to
be on the bridge of a vessel of a
warship and it's going to be going on
the wrong direction and you need to
confidently say hey we need a shift
course right now you can't you can't be
shy about it when you speak
so
those are things that you can definitely
get better at your ability to speak and
write well and look you're gonna have
some natural capability some people are
more articulate
and
good at speaking in public speaking just
naturally they're just naturally good at
it just like some people have good
hand-eye coordination some people have a
good singing voice some people can write
well some people can are better at
writing out of the gate than some other
people it's just the way it is
but you don't have to accept that that's
where you need to be and that's where
you're going to stay you don't have to
you can truly get better at both of
these things
and these are essential tools of
leadership essential tools of leadership
and really if you think about it that's
what leadership actually boils down to
is you're trying to get other humans to
understand what you're saying that's
that's that's what you're doing
so if you can't articulate things well
in both spoken word and written word
you're gonna have problems
did they train you guys actually in in
the marine corps to speak
or is it just ojt cause you're briefing
this and you're briefing that yeah my
recollection for up until like
top gun level stuff they weren't
giving you explicit stuff on speaking
but there was a lot of work on on
writing
and you know in the writing there was i
think they called it was it like a
standard naval letter format there was
like a technique of how to do that and
there was a there was a
book or a publication or like a a guide
on how to do that
um and you know that wasn't like the
most you know creative or unique way to
do it but there was a technique to that
especially if you were trying to run
some paperwork up to get an approval of
something there's a way to do it yeah
and there's a lot of a lot of teaching
on that
the natural tendency thing that you you
spoke to made me think of something is
it was really obvious especially early
in the career
the people that have the the speaking
part specifically the ones that were
just naturally good speakers and how
draw you were to those guys you'd look
at them like damn that was a really good
brief i don't even remember exactly what
he's saying but he said it really well
and how in powerful that capacity is
and to your point that if you weren't
good at it
if you're not careful you'll convince
yourself that oh i'm just not good at
this but dude you could get good at
speaking by just practicing and role
playing rehearsing and listening to
yourself and how important how important
it is to sound good when you're talking
and look if you've got that natural
capacity that's awesome congrats that's
a good thing for you it's going to help
you
but if you don't have that you can
improve on that like quickly if you if
you spend some time on it
somebody sent me a clip the other day
was one of my old
one of my old bosses and he was getting
interviewed and he was like you know the
guy says oh you know
i uh did you ever work with jocko and
he's like yeah i'm on one he would he
worked for me for
whatever 18 months and he goes oh do you
have any good stories about jocko like
what was he like and he goes
he was the thing he was the thing that
i'm going to tell you this is probably
going to let you down the thing that
i'll tell you about jocko is that he was
a really really excellent writer
and i was like
okay that's cool uh fair enough there's
something that you can go to in the navy
it's called master training specialist
and it's where you learn to kind of
become an instructor and they used to
send buds instructors to that school and
the and i had friends that went to it
and they would have to brief you know
they'd have to teach something to a
class i never went to that school i
think that's the closest that you could
get to some kind of a
formal
training
for speaking in the in the navy or at
least in the seal teams maybe there's
more i don't know
um
and speaking of i don't know w if you're
speaking
try and speak about things that you know
about and if you don't know about them
you say i don't know
this is this is one of the biggest uh
ways to level up
in your speaking ability
is when someone says hey jocko can you
explain the flux capacitor on this
engine i go actually i'm not familiar
with flux capacitors you'll have to
check with dave burke on that one right
and just knowing that i can say that
about any subject that i don't
understand well enough
is such a liberating feeling
and
often times people think well if i'm
standing up in front i better know the
answer you don't need to know the answer
to anything you're a human being you're
not a computer
and by the way whatever needs to be
found out can be googled and figured out
really quickly so you don't need to say
hey that's an interesting question why
don't you google it and get back to me
with the answer right there's no reason
to think you have to know the answer to
everything you don't
so
let that be the first thing to level you
up
[Music]
quite frankly now that i think about it
i got taught this when i was when i was
getting ready to do my trident review
board to see if i was going to get my
trident the master chief was like if you
don't know something say you don't know
it don't try and [__] us we'll smash
you and you're like okay fair enough and
that's a great lesson to learn in life
everyone can see through it
so
speaking writing practice them you'll
get better
speaking of speaking and writing this is
an interesting one
uh number 11 there is a salient
difference between profanity and
obscenity
while the leader employs profanity
tempered with discretion he never uses
obscenities
we're talking about some semantics and
splitting some hairs here so from the
dictionary
profanity is blasphemous or obscene
language or a swear word so it's the
word
whereas obscenity
is the state or quality of being obscene
obscene behavior language images an
extremely offensive word or expression
so they're they're definitely a bunch of
cross over there
i that was one that's like the
dictionary definition the fcc
the federal communications what is it
federal communications commission maybe
they had obscene content
is not protected by the first amendment
and it's by obscene content is never
allowed on fcc programming it's not
allowed
there's a three-pronged test
so
number one is it appeals to the per an
average person's sexual interest so that
alone can make it
obscene
depict or describe sexual contact in a
patently offensive way
and the key point here is lack serious
literary artistic political or
scientific value
so that's what obscene means
according to the fcc
profane
and this is something that can make it
onto the fcc sometimes grossly offensive
language that is considered a public
nuisance so you could say a swear word
as long as you weren't using the context
of something offensive
and the way i
i guess the way i try to simplify this
for myself
is that using
profane words sometimes
is okay
but not using them like in the actual
context
that
the word means
i think i got it i'm not 100 sure if we
did a whole freaking podcast like one of
the earliest podcasts we did was about
swearing
and
yeah so
my opinion on swearing is there is
look if you're swearing all the time hey
if you're trying all the time and you're
in the locker room you're at the team
area you're with your buddies whatever
not that big of a deal of course
you start
standing up in front of a group of a
team that you're leading and you're
swearing a bunch isn't it's not gonna
work it's not gonna help it's not gonna
it's it doesn't come across well
and if you develop your vocabulary
hopefully you won't need to swear and if
you're swearing all the time when the
time comes where you do need to swear
it's not powerful
so
that's that's what i'll stick with i
don't know dave any opinion on that one
yeah i mean i think
i'm kind of contemplating what i
remember
people how often people swore in the
military
you know
and so when i get up to top gun like
there's no swearing up there and what
they what they really really wanted to
impress
on you was
they wanted you to be professional
and it's really kind of hard to make the
connection between just you know swear
words and professionalism but i think as
i'm thinking i'm hearing you talk i'm
actually thinking about a little bit of
of the logic behind that i think
something you said it was
kind of really important was
there was this idea and listen i was up
there like predated like social media
predated phones that had cameras like it
but there was this idea that you are
always being watched and what they were
trying to impress upon you is that when
you were a top gun patch and you're in a
squadron space whether you're an
instructor or a former instructor that
patch is going to draw attention to you
i bet it's very much like a trident you
see someone to try to
and look you're going to immediately get
some cred i don't care who you're you're
going to get looked at
and they're going to kind of be like all
right
let's what's this guy all about and if
you have a trident i imagine in in the
navy in the military service that symbol
has meaning
and what they wanted to impress upon us
is that
you are going to be judged at a higher
standard a higher level than
you have ever been because that patch
that you had and they wanted to impress
upon you the need to be a professional
as often as you can
and i think the point you made is
when for whatever reason i chose to use
a profanity
it had much more impact than my my old
methodology once i was you know pre
professional was like just in the
squadron space system i don't even know
how often i swore
so
i think that idea that you're being
judged to a particular standard and
that's true listen what you want from
your people in your organization they
want to feel the obligation to represent
that organization well your team your
company that image whatever it might be
and you can't do that well if every
other word is just some f-bomb because
you don't know how to communicate in
another way so i think the way you
described it is really good you're the
nuance of that
and also the idea that
you are representing something that is
important and if you don't know how to
communicate without using those words
you're not going to represent the
community or that your team very well at
all yeah
i
when my kids were little i never swore
in front of my kids never swore in front
of my wife or very seldom
and then i brought my thought i brought
my son out to uh
to uh a true you know i would bring him
out sometimes to training you know when
he was little and he was at that age
where
you know maybe he
maybe he
[Music]
he knew like he knew swears right you're
hearing him at school it's like oh my
gosh so he knew swears but he never
heard me say anything the first time you
heard me debrief like a platoon you
could see his eyes like just getting
bigger and bigger and bigger he was like
amazed it was like a totally different
scenario um
i got asked at the last monster
i i forget the context of the question
but the question was basically what what
does professionalism mean to you and i
was talking to jason and steve about it
they were backstage and i got this
question they were kind of looking at
each other
and they were like well this hair
uniforms being on time and i'm like
thinking about it and then i say
professionalism to me
is you put the mission
above yourself
and they were like oh that's a good
answer because
look why do you
have a crappy uniform
because you care more about your own
time
why do you show up late oh it's because
you cared more about yourself than you
do about the mission why do your why is
your hair cut out of regs oh it's
because you don't care about the it's
like it's a it's a concise way of saying
that
and
that's the same thing here like if
you're going to act professional
and you're just dropping f-bombs the
whole time
you know who who's recording you who's
listening to you how does that sound
and
is it appropriate for all audience is it
appropriate sometimes to swear hell yes
yes it is and you get into a platoon and
you're trying to make them understand
something
it's going to be cleared hot
but next thing you know that's what's
interesting about the seal teams next
thing you know you're briefing
whatever some civilians about something
and you just have to be professional
so there you go
next one number 12
have consideration for others
isn't this an amazing statement it's
such a big blanket statement
subordinates superiors friends foes have
consideration for
others and if you want to really if you
want to if you want if i can apply some
jocko stretch semantics to this
consideration is also let me understand
what their perspective is let me
understand how this is going to make
them feel let me understand how this is
going to impact someone else
and that's just that's simple
have consideration for others up and
down the chain of command across the
chain of command
competitors allies have consideration
this is one of those things that i see
right away
when there's a lack of it you know and
it
i don't get bothered by a ton of stuff
but lack of consideration is one of
those things that just it gets to me a
little bit you know it's like
how you all got that pet peeve going on
how do you not see it you know how are
you not aware that that there's just a
total lack of consideration and the
impact do you want to answer that
question please yeah the answer that
question is i'm more important than you
so i'll show up late and you'll wait on
me and i won't bring the right gear and
i can borrow yours and
i
whatever the case may be
that's all just me thinking i'm cooler
and you don't really you don't really
matter as much as i do i think that's
where a true lack of consideration for
others is the only thing i consider is
myself right
bad move is a leader
number 13 yelling detracts from your
dignity take men aside to counsel them
straightforward
again um
i think it's funny you know life said
has to say like yo choco looks like he
yells do i look like a yell
and then he always has to say but he he
never yelled at me right and
okay and life will say i gave jocko
hundreds of opportunities or situations
where i probably deserve to get yell at
yelled at um which is funny
but yeah i'm not yelling i mean think
about where you're at
think about how effective you are as a
communicator if you get to a point where
you're yelling at someone
look i'm if i'm yelling at you to tell
you to get away from the freaking
edge of the building because you're
about to slip obviously if i have to
yell at you to get over the sound of
machine gun fire obviously if i have to
get if i have to raise my voice so
everyone in the room can hear me that's
not what we're talking about but me
yelling at you in front of the team is
just no it's just stupid um and he's
specific about like yelling at people
in front of the group to
to berate them
for a mistake that they've made
no don't do it and i'm gonna say don't
do it just don't do it
would you write down over there dave
well you've said something in the past
and
and i think there's an element to what
he's saying that you can even take it a
step further as
listen
yelling at somebody else in front of a
whole bunch of other people i i can't i
cannot think of a time when that's okay
and i'm not talking about raising your
voice to get a particular action because
the sound is loud i'm talking like we're
in the we got the team jocko screw
something up and i start yelling at
jocko so i i can't even imagine a
scenario where that's okay but
you even talked about it too like the
times that you've had to yell at someone
or raise your voice i think the element
that you've talked about that's so
important is that
you were aware of that yeah that was
based on an escalation of a whole series
of other approaches that did not get the
reaction
which is different than
yeah jaco like i just lost my temper i
just no longer had control of myself and
i just started screaming at somebody
you know even inside the idea of yelling
which
on very rare occasions there are some
times that you're gonna have to do that
that you're still aware that you're
doing that yeah as opposed to just well
you know i just got a bad temper and
that's just kind of how i am so i can't
control myself and i look back and go
wow i shouldn't have done that i didn't
even realize i was doing i totally lost
control in a leadership role and how
important i think that story of even the
few times in your career you've had to
do that
you knew what you were doing yeah yeah i
cannot think of any situation where i
yelled without thinking about like okay
i need to yell right now
and yeah let's say you get a group let's
say your whole platoon's there and also
you get somebody that does something
really stupid and it's an opportunity
for everyone to see hey this can't
happen and obviously i haven't gotten
that message across sure i might dress
someone down in front of everybody and i
might yell
i really can't think of any times that i
did that in my 20-year career that i
offed on my head but yeah and it's not
going to be on accident yeah because you
just lost control no yeah that's not
happening
so don't be yelling number 14
understand and use judgment
know when to stop fighting for something
you believe is right
okay
this is where we might start to get
derailed on some stuff so first of all
it's interesting that he says understand
and use judgment
so there's a conjunction there the first
thing is just understand
which is an easy word to say but it can
be very difficult to do
so so try and understand the situation
and the reason that he has to say this
is because so often people do things
without understanding what's happening
so he's telling you
understand
understand what's going on that's what
you have to do
and the same thing is use judgment do
you think that someone would have to
tell a leader to understand and to use
judgment no why does he have to say that
in here because people all the time
neither understand nor use judgment
so be careful with those two now he says
know when to stop fighting for something
you believe is right
and
here's where
i probably have uh the first maybe um
separation
in understanding or separation in belief
in what he's saying here
maybe it's not but
i
i think most of the time
i'm not fighting
for something i believe to be right
because i don't really care if i'm right
or not and the reason i don't care if
i'm right or not is because most things
don't actually matter
that's why
so so dave believes we should do it one
way dave's believes we should attack the
target from the north i believe we
should attack it from the west and
i'm gonna fight about that most of the
time it doesn't matter north or west
doesn't just it just doesn't matter dave
wants to invest eighteen thousand
dollars in this
software system
i wanna invest twelve thousand in a
different system
and guess what
it probably doesn't matter there's some
advantages of the 18 000 there's some
advantage to 12 000 we don't really know
how it's going to impact we've never
done this kind of interface before and
i'm going to commit my relationship
value my my leadership capital like i'm
going to commit all this stuff to me
just thinking i'm going to be right i'm
an art no
no i'm not gonna do that it's just a
stupid thing to do
so
99 of the time these things that we're
fighting for actually don't matter or
you're fighting for something that's in
the future that you don't know the
actual outcome to
so that's most of the time for me and
that's a very powerful lesson
is you're sitting there thinking but i
want to do it my way and it doesn't
matter
we should use this marketing company not
that marketing company we should invest
in this piece of equipment or that piece
of equipment
i want to get this backhoe and not that
backhoe guess what
it probably doesn't matter that much and
by the way if it does matter that much
and there's a real reason and i say hey
dave the reason i like this backhoe
better is he has the following
capabilities that tobacco you want to
get done doesn't have it can do this
this this and this it's this more
efficient and boom does this make sense
to you
if i can't articulate the reason why
something is better it's probably not
worth arguing over so there's your
litmus test let's let's put that one
write that one down
if you're having a hard time
articulating why your plan is better
than someone else's plan your plan is
probably not worth arguing over because
it's too hard for you to clarify the
reason it's hard for you to clarify
because they're both basically the same
thing
or there's risk involved in both of
those items
so this idea to know when you stop
fighting for something you believe in
right first thing i'm going to run this
thing through a filter
that is so powerful that the filter's
going to filter out most of the
arguments i'm going to have with people
because it doesn't really matter most
things don't matter look are there
occasional things that matter yes there
are occasional things that matter and
when those things that matter it's so
easy to articulate why they matter and
it's so easy to sway people's opinions
because the facts are there
so it doesn't turn into an argument it
turns into hey let me let me ask you
some earnest questions about what you
think and let me give you my perspective
over here and people see it
so i don't generally have to know when
to stop fighting for something i believe
right because i'm generally not fighting
for it
and when i do when i do need to approach
somebody about something all i need to
do is ask them some earnest questions
and they the truth is revealed to them
by them answering their own questions
this is i mean there's a lot inside this
and and
just trying to like imagine the affront
to your ego
when someone says stop fighting for what
you think is right yeah you're like i
will never
stop fighting and what this is probably
from is someone who's observed
hundreds of people sell all their
leadership capital all their credibility
over something that literally does not
matter
i was with the company they were doing a
workshop about picking a logo for their
company
and they kind of narrowed it down to
three different options i looked at the
three and they're like
they were all pretty good one was like
and the other two were like pretty good
and so sort of quickly it got to like
we're not gonna do b but a and c are
they're good they were both good cool
and
you know what
you could make a case for a you could
make a case for c
which tells me like
they're both good they're both good
which means it doesn't matter but what
we started to see was like the a group
and the c group are not going to budge
and if you use this the phrase like hey
jocko i know you're supporting on a i
want you to stop fighting for what you
think is right if i say it like that
like it's almost impossible for you to
say okay
but the part that you're emphasizing
which is so important is the idea that
it doesn't matter and how quickly you
can get entrenched into something
that you will sell every piece of
credibility you have which means your
influence in the future
can go to zero because you want the
round logo and i want the square logo
yep and by the way so you're taking all
that all that leadership capital and all
that future influence and you're putting
it all on there you're pushing it all in
you're going all in on this thing that
doesn't really even freaking matter
and and a gamble because you look up in
six months and like hey this logo we're
not getting the traction we want but you
put all in and now you look like an
idiot instead of going you know what
dave yeah we'll go with c that looks
they're pretty close cool sounds good
man i i reserved oh i kept all my money
to myself i kept all my leadership
capital i kept all my future in fact i
made
because i agreed with you because i
supported your plan i got a little bit
more i took some more off the table i
actually grew my leadership capital in
that moment
and now when we look up in six months
and your logo that you picked isn't
really getting the traction we wanted to
i get even more because i say okay well
you know we tried it doesn't seem like
we're getting the tracks we want do you
want to try this other logo now boom and
all of a sudden i and now my logo goes
out and wins i get even more leadership
it's like crazy
but we'll burn our bridges and throw
away our leadership capital
over over what's the word here
fighting to build something we believe
is right
it's this is not the way to view the
world
the way to view the world is that 99 of
things don't matter
and then they're in the future and look
if you come to me with a logo that's
freaking stupid totally you know
i'm like hey dave that logo that you put
together he's like how do you like it
dave uh just so you know it's pretty
much looks like a swastika you know but
it's orange and you're like ooh
or you know like okay maybe we should
not go with that right okay you're like
oh i didn't even see that okay great you
know boom we're done
or you know you approach me hey jacob
what do you think of this oh dave it's a
pentagram like no we're not going to use
satanic ritual stuff or not okay cool
you're like got it how did i not see
that boom so we're done but you're like
it's a star but you know i want to show
that we're we're we're flipping over the
star yeah that's a pentagram dude
so so you see where we're going this
the chances that you come to me with a
logo that's unusable is almost almost
non-existent
and we want to fight about things that
we quote believe is right and it's not
worth it and you're throwing away
leadership capital and by the way if
there is something that's completely
wrong and it is time to stand your
ground because someone's doing something
immoral unethical or illegal then cool
that's where you hold the line of course
somebody wants to do something that is
you are morally against
somebody wants to rip off a client and
you're like hey we're not doing that
we're not doing that like okay
so we want to make an you know put some
product out there that's dangerous and
it's we got some flaw in it but you know
what let's just sell it anyways no we're
not doing that that's all we're talking
about and if that happens of course
then you you you take the right action
and you don't back down
and even in that case what you need more
than anything in those cases is
leadership capitalists credibility is a
reputation of someone who
only
digs in
on those yeah and if you're going to
sell it all on round versus square or or
red versus blue on the logo
when those important times do come
nobody's gonna listen to you when it
actually matters they're not gonna
listen to you because they're so used to
you saying
i am not giving up my position it's logo
a or death like come on man
so there's some human nature here this
guy's you know obviously he's seen of
people willing to dig in on things that
just don't matter and then when it does
matter nobody's listening to you yeah
and uh at ashland front you know jamie
our our clo
she's told me like if i push back
against her like
more than twice she's like she says to
herself like i'm wrong about this i
gotta go figure this something out
there's something i
i'm wrong
she's like if you're pushing back
against me if you ask me like three
questions i'm like oh there's something
i don't see here i'm wrong i'm gonna go
figure this out and it's because 99 of
the time i'm like yeah it sounds good
yep go execute yep sounds good yeah
that's a better plan than i had boom
boom boom so when i say eat pump the
break she's like ooh there's something
wrong
as opposed to her thinking oh god he
never likes anything oh here we go what
do you know how do you want to do it
john it's like no
don't don't back yourself into that
corner that's that healthy sense of
self-doubt you've talked about before i
think that you know jamie's a perfect
example of where
you know
if you believe you're right how often
are you really believing that you're
percent right if that's if you're if
that's a pretty regular thing
you might want to check that you know
i know i'm not right
a lot of the time you know so and if
somebody else is giving you some
feedback maybe listen to that too you
know and like jamie if if she starts to
get some feedback she has that humility
to say what am i not seeing here how can
you know how can i solve this problem
yeah yeah don't put yourself in that
position so there you go that's i guess
my first disagreement a little bit
with uh with glover john's here um last
couple points here number 15
and this is another one that
okay so number 15. discuss and argue
your point of view until a decision is
made
and then support the decision
wholeheartedly
so
again just using the term argue and
saying argue your point of view
i'm not gonna i need to argue my point
of view because i'm not married to my
point of view because the chances are
you see something that i don't see the
chances are i'm not 100 right the
chances are my idea is flawed
that's what the chances are
so i'm not going to quote argue my point
of view
until a decision is made i don't need to
i might ask earnest questions i might
try and see your perspective i might try
and understand why i might ask you why
this is the best way but i'm not quote
arguing my point of view
because what is my is my subordinates
plan so freaking crazy is my boss's plan
so totally insane
that i need to completely argue against
it this is basically a run-on off the
last the last statement i don't need to
argue
because i'm not married to my plan
because my plan could be wrong and it
probably needs adjustments
and it by the way if it's so awesome and
your plan sucks so bad it's not i don't
have to argue it for very long because i
go hey dave your plan is to do this and
if we do that we're going to lose all
this and you go oh
cool what did you want to do and i go i
want to do this and you go that sounds
good
so
we shouldn't have to quote argue now
when a decision gets made
i am going to do my damnedest to execute
on that thing but you know i try and
think of all my life and the times that
i got told you know what jonko what your
your points are taken we don't care go
and execute this other thing that's the
opposite i just can't think of
situations where that happened
i just can't think of situations where
people said hey shut up jocko do what i
told you to do that's it
and and i'm thinking oh this is gonna
have a terrible outcome
there's times where i've said you know
this might be not this isn't to be quite
as efficient
or this might take a little bit longer
or there might be a higher risk on this
maneuver over here
but
by doing that higher maneuver risk we're
going to save some some speed and
security over on this other side so
there's i've never just like had an
idiotic plan that i wasn't able to say
hey boss can i talk this through with
you or hey you know subordinate can you
talk me through this so we can
understand it better
yeah
um
i think that's pretty straightforward
yeah i think there's again some some
human nature inside there i'm kind of
picturing again these scenarios that
have played out in my life as i'm
hearing you talk about the explanation
of this this leadership attribute this
behavior you want to apply
top gun this happened a lot this
discussion these debates on
right or wrong or how we should do
something and we would do these things
called staff x's staff exercises so
class would be over it's the 25
instructors we'd lock the door and we
would have
debates over how we should do
we were very sop heavy we had
standardization across the board there
was a way to do a lot of things not
everything but a lot of things and our
job was to standardize it so we could
teach it and we would at the end of each
class talk about what worked and what
didn't and what we needed to change and
there'd be different camps there'd be
one camp that said we should do it like
this another camp that should do it like
that now what was interesting about that
is it
they weren't like 90 10 where all this
one camp is i have this awesome plan
this other camp has this awful stupid
plan they're actually both camps like
damn those are
too big these are pretty good plans yeah
those are pretty good ideas i see the
merits of that i see the merits of this
and listen we we wanted
arguing is the wrong word because that
has a kind of a negative tone but like
pretty healthy debate dudes go back and
forth and they would they would dig in
to to really make sure they was
understood and it was managed by a guy
who who ran these meetings and he was
called the standardization officer who
who facilitated like all right what do
you think in there jacob why are we
doing that and i would capture those in
notes and say okay what he's saying is
this
listen in the end
there was a winning side and a losing
side and then we had to make a decision
so you'd have this group of people that
believed in a certain approach and in
the end we would pick a different
approach
where the problem would come which
sometimes is someone's ego would come
into play we'd then go implement this
with a squadron or a class or something
and then i'd sit down and i go hey the
way we're going to do this uh this
problem jacob we're going to do it like
that you're like why and i'd say
well listen i actually didn't want to do
it this way
but here's how we're going to do it so
that little need for me to still be
right
for me to get my way and not accept the
outcome i would poison
the reality of
and it's the part you said that's so
important so we don't really know if we
knew there wouldn't be a debate and so
the only way to find out is actually go
out there and do it but rather than me
say hey here's the reasons why a b c and
d let's go execute get some good
feedback i'd say
i didn't really want to do this i
actually think this is kind of dumb but
we're going to go do it anyway now what
are the chances if i take that approach
that when we go execute i'm really going
to get the feedback to come back and go
hey guys
we executed on this plan three times and
look it did not work we need to make
some changes
i think okay cool let's go back to the
drawing work i'll do that all day long
and we'd see it rarely but we'd see guys
go well
i didn't get my way so i'm not really
i'm not going to support this plan i'm
going to let you know that yeah we're
going to go do this but i think this is
dumb and there's no way that's going to
work so inside that of hey if you lose
the debate if you lose the argument you
don't get your way
unless you are convinced that the other
side is is there to destroy the company
don't just agree with it get on board
get on board and the best it'll work and
it or she'll come back go hey man hey
jock we ran this a couple times there's
some feedback here we can make some
tweaks and now i can take that plan and
i can influence and get a better outcome
for the team yeah uh
i think jason gardner at the muster was
like oh what's the best plan
my plan of course that's where everyone
everyone thinks my plan's the best plan
uh and so so then we go what we're
talking about right now
is we're talking about a situation we've
got six and one half dozen the other
right we've got six and one half dozen
the other okay cool
dave's got six i'm saying half dozen if
we're having that hard of a time
figuring out whether to go six or a half
dozen
guess what
they're both kind equally valid and
guess what my default is
my default is you know what dave sounds
good let's go with your plan say look
i'm i'm thinking half dozen you're
thinking six let's go with your plan
right now and i'm gonna execute just
like you just said i'm gonna execute it
to the absolute best of my ability that
way we can see if it works or not and by
the way as long as i didn't dig my heels
in like a jackass if i said you know you
said your sign i said well hey what
about this dave and you said yeah i know
but most the time and i go well okay you
know what you know it seems like yours
covers the same thing for the most part
it's a little bit of a different
direction but let's let's give it a shot
i'm down
and my leadership capital just went up
and i don't look like an idiot the
person that looks like nudity is like no
my points are more important than your
points
so
my default mode
when we're in a 50 actually my default
mode is like hey we're going to go with
dave's plan but certainly in a 50 50
situation it's like it doesn't matter
see it still doesn't matter because as
you first started talking through that i
was like oh so this is something that
matters you got this people saying this
and but no you can't satisfy both things
well i guess maybe you could find a
compromise that you could you could
create
but in lieu of some kind of a compromise
you know you either do this procedure or
that procedure
when this happens when you get this tail
lock on your plane you can do this or
this and there's some advantage to this
and there's advantages of that
okay
they both have advantages
guess what which one do you want to do
dave you wanna do this one cool we'll do
that one for we'll do we'll do this one
for now boom it's so easy
so again
i don't have to argue my point of view
because i'm not gonna back myself into a
corner because i'm not gonna give away
my position
because i'm not gonna be married to
something that i don't know about that
that we can't determine the impact of
the future on
people want to bet so much on the future
when we don't know what's going to
happen in the future yeah it's crazy and
think about what i do to the
relationship if i do what you just said
and i go hey you know what
i honestly dude i came in coming with
the plan of going you know six and i
hear you wanna go half dozen hey let's
go execute and if i project in my mind
the next conversation we're gonna have
i'm gonna win on both because i'm gonna
come back and go hey dude i did your
plan dude it was awesome man we crushed
it that was awesome man thank you for
that feedback the team did really well
and we're it's awesome or i come back go
dude i ran with the half dozen plan man
and we kind of got rolled a couple times
here what are you seeing like i'm kind
of seeing the same thing but either way
we're good
but if i don't take that approach
that next conversation about the future
that we do not know
is almost always gonna have some sort of
friction there's gonna be some argument
so i can even just project in my mind by
going with your plan
i'm gonna win no matter what because
then come back and go dude you're
awesome great idea thanks bro i'm gonna
come back go dude i'm still struggling
can you walk me through this we are not
getting past these steps and you're
gonna either go hey dude we're having
the exact same problem so we might need
to go back to the drawing board or oh
hey that's a great question we did this
this and this either way we're winning
because the team the team is winning and
our relationship is stronger for it and
you see guys all the time just dig in
i
very often see losing as a winning and
this is a classic situation oh dave i
was wrong you were right you're awesome
to me i wrote about that in leadership
strategy and tactics i'm like hey it
gives me the opportunity to prove how
humble i am because by the way i'm
running around trying to make calls
trying to make decisions and yeah i'm
the one that's having to put word out
and when all of a sudden dave does
something better i go hey dave dude
awesome work man you were definitely
right about it being a half dozen and
not six sweet
that's an opportunity for me and yet
people see it as losing and they won't
take it
so be careful of this one
um last one
pretty straightforward stay ahead of
your moss
kind of brilliant right stay ahead of
your boss and and stay ahead of the
power curve
uh to me stay at your boss another way
of thinking about this is
when it comes to
functioning as a human think strategic
and think long term that's how you stay
ahead of your boss you stay ahead of
your boss by your boss says there's a
fire right now put it out and you go
cool got it boss and then you look to
see where that next fire is going to be
it's as simple as that
it's as simple as that stay ahead of
your boss
[Music]
make your boss look good again
leadership strategy and taxes make it
yeah make your boss look good
what an incredible way to build a good
relationship with your boss what an
incredible way to build leadership
capital your boss make your boss look
good
that's my goal
do i want the credit no i want dave
burke my boss to get the credit that's
what i want i want him to look awesome
you think dave burke's not going to take
care of me all day
so
once dave burke is taking care of me
guess what i can do i can take care of
my team and that's my mission well now i
can take care of my team now we can take
care of the mission and and life is good
that's what we're doing
and this is another thing that seems
hard and it's not this is not hard
and if we spend less time lamenting
everything wrong with our bot you were
talking about the ocd boss a couple you
know minutes ago about hey and it worked
for an ocd boss yeah i remember and i
immediately
this guy came to mind
and
people hated working for him they hated
working for him and look i worked from
it was not easy at first i had to figure
him out but once i figured him out it
was super easy to work for him because i
knew what he wanted and i could stay
ahead of him and i could
anticipate the things that he needed and
if you just spend less time thinking
about what's wrong with your boss and
all the dumb things he's making you do
and spend more time thinking like all
right what is he trying to get
accomplished what's his personality like
what do i need to do to get ahead of him
to help him so i can help the team
cracking that code is usually not that
hard and when you crack the code
not only does your boss lives get better
your life gets so much better it's so
much easier
and just like you described to push that
down to the team that's where that's
where the win is it's like you can take
care of your team you can help your team
you can make sure your team's successful
so if you're looking at this about how
hard that is that's just your ego
telling you well your boss is the
problem
there's nothing wrong with your boss
just figure out what he wants and get
ahead of him and it's really really not
that hard
all right well there you go
those are some uh some simple rules for
being a better leader and a better
follower and a better human
and here's the thing got to pay
attention to you can only see these
things
if you detach
and by the way
when you detach and you take a step back
the thing that you really have to detach
from is still part of you it's your ego
it's driving so many of these mistakes
that we make
so you can't just detach from the
situation you can't just detach from
your boss you can't just detach from the
plan you got to detach and be able to
see your own ego which is probably the
root of 97
of these problems so take a step back
write these things down write these
rules down just go go
take about face write these rules down
go read them before you go to a meeting
read them before you make a decision
read them before you meet with your
subordinate
read through
at the end just check yourself how'd you
do on them
and eventually over time this is how you
become better because
you won't rely on having to read through
these things you'll you'll start to know
them and they will become
second nature
so there you go
all right with that
we
carry why are you here
just so everyone knows
people that are freaking out right now
uh echo charles he needed a break bro
he was i mean the stress level was high
he hadn't been cruising in at least a
few days
and so echo charles don't worry
everybody ec will be back
he he's okay
he just had to reset you know had it
recharged the batteries recharged the
the mana yeah
back on yeah back on the island yeah so
he had to go get some island time in
that's where echo's been he'll be back
hopefully i don't know you never know
we'll see maybe
you know he'll make the call whatever
it's no factor keep covering whatever
whatever echo needs
we're just here so so don't worry this
is still the echo podcast he'll be back
um
it's kind of a lose-lose for you isn't
it carrie being here
i mean it's it's hard look
you know uh echo
he's kind of got that thing going where
people just he's just nice and kind of
like if you if you do something
anything different than him even if you
do the same thing as him people are like
well oh look are you trying to try to be
like trying to jack echo style
you're in a lose-lose situation bro hey
i'm just happy to be here man you know
just happy to be here sitting in the hot
seat everything press and record over
there
it's awesome man to get the cover down
and yeah when when he comes back i'll be
back in the shadows back in the shadows
retreat to the shadows or maybe he'll
get whacked
he'll just be like well looks like i'm
in here now
he won't give up the chair yeah you
ain't giving up the chair dude he gets
bummed out
we were doing
jordan peterson and he was it got
scheduled and he was going to be in
hawaii and he wasn't around he was
bummed about that
yeah
we were we were talking about that you
know the the tim kennedy podcast you
know yeah he was kind of bummed about
that one too
yeah
that was a good one man it was that was
that one went by quick for how long it
was how long it was
almost five hours and 50 minutes and
then i was like oh that's a long but
also huberman was humong was five hours
and 20 minutes
and of course sean parnell was five
hours and 25 minutes or something like
this that's a long time to be talking if
we were better uh
at milking
we would just break it up into four
different podcasts no hey don't worry
people we got you
we got you we're here we're gonna put it
out one one one hit a little bit of that
immediate gratification for you
i know there's some people that look at
that thing they see five hours in 50
minutes and they go oh damn let me get
that 2x on
feed that up and there's also some
people that are like hell yeah yeah oh
for sure i'm definitely in that camp
anytime i see a
five-hour jocko podcast
no it's like yes well the thing is
there's no time limit in either
direction yeah i'm not there's no goal
right that we could go an hour we can go
five hours i don't know we go 12 hours
we go 30 minutes
if it's there
we'll roll with it we're getting it yeah
that's it
see tim and i had a lot of
you know with the fight background and
he was doing all that stuff when i was
like we were in the game right
at the same time i was like older i
think i'm
i'm maybe eight years older than him or
something like this
and so
but you know
chuck liddell i just saw chuck liddell
at the ufc he said what's up
how was that ufc it's cool it was good
man it was awesome um
but we were so we had a lot to talk
about there you know um
but echo charles be back with his
powerful questions and opinions
standing by until then uh speaking of
being strategic make sure you stay in
shape make sure you keep your health
that's strategic move keep stay healthy
you know how you do that jocklefield
jockofield.com how's the new flavors
dave so just fyi
we
have an energy drink it's called
go
and it will give you energy
when we initially made it the
the taste profile was based on my taste
buds which are not normal
my taste buds are hyper sensitive to the
sweetness and so i tried these things i
was like oh yeah that's very sweet
that's you know this is good to go this
basically tastes like a coca-cola to me
right now it's like just
well i was wrong and a lot of people
that normally eat a lot of sugar they
were like what is this doesn't taste
good so we redid all the flavors all of
them
dave you got your new
afterburn orange how was that going down
today that's good
i'm in a similar boat i never drank an
energy drink before go ever i don't
drink them so i had no frame of
reference
when we made the orange i got to do all
the flavor testing and all that stuff at
the end i'm like this thing is
incredible it tastes like an orange
crush or whatever
the i've had almost all not all i've had
almost all the new flavors and they are
ridiculously good tasting so i'm over
here thinking like all right i'm doing
timing i'm doing reasons i gotta
anticipate all these
now it's just like i just wanna i just
want the way it tastes
yeah
i'm drinking the citrus psycho which was
by far our worst seller and the reason
it's our worst sellers because the first
one that came out before i had any
semblance of trying to make things taste
good for the world at large
and now this one is
freaking delicious so leif babin's
haterade here citrus psycho it tastes
like
there's a reason that this was the first
flavor that we made by the way the
reason this is the first flavor that we
made was because i thought to myself
what's the like common
flavor that everybody likes
eat you know well it's
lemon lime look at look at gatorade look
at sprite
um all those flavors and it's like hey
lemon lime this is a this is a
standard flavor it's like chocolate
vanilla right it's the same thing oh
you're gonna make a protein shake cool
chocolate
or vanilla or strawberry that's what
that's what this was to me so this was
the first flavor that's why
but
man i didn't sweeten it enough
and now this thing is and it's still
it's still sugar-free it's still keto
it's still
all natural it's still pasteurized it's
still freaking
this all the same qualities of
awesomeness but it tastes delicious so
there you go jacofuel.com uh check all
that stuff out check out some mulk do
you have some mulch over the fourth of
july of course i'm up i was uh talking
about that on on that last podcast i've
i'm up to two milkshakes a day now yeah
because once you start tracking them
macros yeah you need that extra hitter
of protein you got it too yeah if it can
be uh measured it can be managed or what
do you know two scoops in a in a mark or
do you go one no i go one
i double it up you double it up
double up that hitter uh jockofield.com
go to wawa if you want the drinks
go to vitamin shop go to heb down in
tejas we got you
and try the new flavors the new flavors
are kind of hitting the stores right now
so
what's it july by august i think we'll
be in all new flavors but go go get em
originusa.com get some cool
american-made apparel
oh up at the ufc a lot of people were
pumped a lot of people were pumped on
the hunt line coming out on the you know
i had guys every key i have is an origin
key i'm like hell yeah
so if you want to get on the american
made a train then go to origin usa.com
get yourself jiu-jitsu jeans
people representing the genes that's
freaking legit you know it's a sad day
when your iconic american jeans are not
made in america but guess what they are
now because now the only pair of iconic
jeans you can get
is good old origin usa.com
get some of that jackal store
that's where we have stuff that
might help you on the path might help
you on the path uh
echo's been busy too on some some new
discipline equals freedom shirts really
some new ones yeah go check those out uh
some new colors on there and there's
like a little bit of a jiu jitsu line
that's forming as well yes that jiu
jitsu
t-shirt is quite popular it is it is
it's super clean and then we've got the
the dean lisch on there as well
do you have the foot soldier one yet i
want to make a fl he's he's got that
little sticker that says foot soldier
and it's like a dean lister and like a
nom style helmet and it just says foot
soldier we gotta get that come on we've
got the foot the foot
yeah so there you go but also shirt
locker uh new shirt every month with
that and we've been just going
going pretty hard on those um
the uh
the last month was was pretty awesome if
you if you get what was last month's
shirt uh or it might have been a month
before last i think uh the we did kind
of a gi joe style oh yeah yeah that was
the discipline one but it looks gi
joe-ish right right and then the charlie
mike was i believe after that so there
you go uh jockostore.com you can check
some of that out subscribe to the
podcast taco underground jocko
underground
jockonderground.com if you want to if
you're if you're nervous about the
platform
look we don't own the platform that
you're listening to unless you're
listening to us right now on
jockunderground.com then we own it no
one can stop us we got that but if
you're listening on some of the other
platforms that are out there look we
don't own them and they could shut us
down they could censor us maybe they
don't want us talking about war maybe
they don't want us talking about
whatever we're talking about
and we got to be aware of that we have a
contingency plan so jocklerground.com
is a contingency there
and i've written a bunch of books if you
want to check out the books that i've
written go to amazon and buy them all
[Laughter]
uh we have echelon front dave and i work
at echelon front we solve problems
through leadership we take these
principles of combat leadership we teach
people how to apply them inside their
business get your business aligned
around leadership if you have leaders if
you have problems they're leadership
problems so echelonfront.com come to the
mustard next musters in atlanta hotlanta
october 12th through the 14th we're
gonna sell it out we sell out everything
so come and check that out
we have the extreme ownership academy
online extreme ownership.com
we got courses we're about to record a
course today we're doing a course on
relationships and the value of
relationships how to build relationships
how to maintain relationships
why relationships are so powerful
so
these are the kind of conversations that
we have on that
platform
that you can
study you can test you can learn and
leadership is not an inoculation you
can't look you can't read extreme
ownership one time be like cool got it
it doesn't work
and for a while i'd say well you know
you want some more of that stuff listen
to the podcast but then now there's
341 podcasts there's hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of hours i can't
say let's go listen to the podcast now
we had to we had to streamline it and
distill it down
the the principles so that people could
learn them and actively train in them
just like you go to the gym just like
you train jiu jitsu just like you pick
up your get box and play guitar at night
if you're not practicing you're you're
not learning
so go to extremeownership.com check out
the courses also i'm on there live a
bunch at least once a week i'm on there
answering questions so extreme
ownership.com come and check that out
also if you want to help service members
active and retired their families gold
star families check out mark lee's mom
mama lee she's got an awesome charity
organization she helps with health
issues
putting putting service members through
health protocols that aren't paid for by
the military but that are extremely
helpful so
america's mightywarriors.org
check that out if you want to donate or
you want to get involved also check out
heroes and horses.org micah he's up
there in the mountains right now i'm
just getting it
teaching people what's up
um and of course on twitter on the gram
on facebook dave's at david r burke
carries that carry underscore
helton he didn't get that he didn't get
the real one
not fast you had to throw that
underscore in there too slow yep just a
just a forever sign of being a little
too slow
everybody knows
uh and if you want to see me on there
i'm at jacqueline no underscore in there
no period no dot nothing just got in
there deep early
coming at you uh while you're in there
just watch out because the algorithm
might grab you by the by the leg and
start dragging you down
um so be careful of that
and thanks to all our military personnel
out there
the current and future glover johns
thanks for doing what you are doing out
there every day to lead and protect our
country and the same goes to our police
and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emts dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol secret service
all you first responders thank you for
what you do every day to protect us here
at home
and everyone else just try and remember
and implement these simple lessons from
glover john's things like do the small
things well things like be a doer and a
self-starter
never be satisfied
have consideration of others
remember that the harder the training
the more the troops are gonna brag
these are all things
that are simple but not easy but if you
do get them and you do implement them
you'll be a better leader
and you'll be a better human being
so go out there
and get after it
and until next time this is dave and
carrie and jocko